a las puertas de la sede Naciones Unidas
en Nueva York en la celebración de la
asamblea general número 77 aquí todavía
sigue habiendo mucha seguridad porque
siguen llegando políticos representantes
y líderes mundiales la mayoría de las
calles alrededor de este organismo están
cortadas vemos también que todavía hay
prensa esperando a los últimos los
últimos discursos en esta tercera
jornada pero desde luego lo más
importante que ha pasado hoy ha sido
esta misma mañana cuando ha habido una
reunión del Consejo de Seguridad a
petición de Francia y tras las
declaraciones del presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin hoy esta mañana los
ministros exteriores ucranianos y Ruso
han compartido sala se han sentado uno
muy cerca del otro y ambos han puesto
encima de la mesa su manera de ver la
guerra por su parte Rusia le ha dicho a
occidente que ayudar a Ucrania
prestándole armas es implicarse
directamente en esta guerra ha dicho que
ellos son inocentes que ellos no han
hecho nada de lo que se le culpa y ya
recordado ataques en el bombas del 2014
por su parte el representante ucraniano
ha pedido más armas y ha pedido también
un tribunal que juzgue las acciones de
Rusia ha sido muy interesante la
participación de China que hasta ahora
se había mantenido neutral Pues bien ha
llamado al diálogo pero un diálogo con
un plan con unas serie de directrices
encima de la mesa para acabar con esta
guerra interesante también que ha
contado la reunión de hoy con la
presencia del jefe del fiscal jefe de la
Corte Penal Internacional que ha dicho
que la próxima semana Se enviará una
comitiva a Ucrania para que investigue
esos presuntos crímenes contra la
población civil